where that's like the only indicator of
of women's success but that's not it
um okay so my next question how
old
is too old to be dating
for men and for women
I'm too old all right no I'll go quick
what does that mean yeah like okay
you know when someone's in the NBA right
and they're playing yeah
they're going hard you know they're in
their 20s in their 30s they're chilling
at some point people are going to look
and say you are too old to be here
you need to hang up them yeah you need
to you need to hang up hang up the
Jersey okay all right and so for men and
for women how old because I know the
manosphere will talk about men age
better they do but I think at some point
too
man in a way need to hang up the Jersey
I know that's not going to be popular
with my audience but at some point like
the club lights go off so
yeah yeah
um
what age what age
you know what to be fair let's start
with the guys I think it's different for
everyone
you want to retire when you want to
retire
um
I think if you've established
what you've needed
when you're coming up like so you've got
your kids
all right you know maybe a relationship
didn't work out yada yada but dating
dating what's the intention after say
50 for a guy what what what are you
hoping to get at 50.
I think I'm ready to just Coronation
Street it and just chill out and just
you know you've got your long time
someone you know that you just survived
with and
you know you hook up once in a while but
I don't see me sitting at the table oh
it's nice to meet you on a date over 50.
did you hear what you just said uh no
probably not when he hits 50 I'm just
saying it for the younger people when
he's 50 he's just looking for someone to
chill and hook up with right and that's
an older man so when you're at 50 you're
looking for like anybody to settle down
because you've got everything you want
you don't want anybody like over 35 you
don't want anybody your age you want
just want somebody to hook up with yeah
and if you're gonna hook up with
somebody it's gonna be somebody younger
it's going to be okay it's gonna be and
then you can just check the chat just
have one two things
yeah but for a female
I don't know I don't know
probably sudo
so put an age
I'm just trying to think of an age you
know what I I don't know I'm gonna tell
you why because I don't know what
a 48 year old woman's looking for at 48.
I don't know what are you looking for
like what do you want
what were you looking for yeah maybe you
know what that's it it's a learning what
are you looking for at 50 years old I'm
not looking for nothing because I'm all
right but I know that people are out
there looking what are they looking for
what they can't get what they should
have been looking for at 30 and 25. okay
and I was just thinking about that
question my answer is
what age do you stop dating
not a single parent when your children
leave Primary School
okay
whatever age it is watch your children
all finished primary school they move on
to secondary school don't bother
right because no man what no man come on
you don't mind having somebody with kids
at Primary School yeah but you don't
want to be dating somebody and they're
like because I heard somebody on one of
your shows like oh it's all right when
there's a 17 year old next door you know
you don't want that definitely don't
worry so as far as I'm concerned it's
not the age of the purse of the woman
it's as she's got children when your
children is primary school don't even
think about dating just wait for old man
to hook you up right so so yeah so just
grab it depends what where what we're
calling dating dating
how are we call it what it's almost like
the question is like when because
I think that love is a Young Person's
game yeah and at some point you're not
really dating like to find love anymore
it's just to find something that works
so I'm not phrasing this in the best way
but like when when is it just we're just
gonna hook up because we're both in the
same place looking for the same thing
fine let's do it I don't want to die
alone and what
yeah so when like that's one and then
there's another point where you fall in
love you get married and have kids when
when is retirement okay right so if I'm
single and I've got no children
this is what I'm saying to you okay men
don't retire men don't retire yeah they
don't retire 65
70.
they don't trust me they don't they
still want to pass on their legacy
whether they're going to be there for
five minutes
yeah right they're out so depending on
your situation if you have a family
you've created children you've created
your legacy your children on a thriving
successful then
you know you're not really looking today
you're just doing your thing
man are just doing this thing yeah what
do you think I don't know I had a
question okay regarding like
um so you see the way you were saying
how well you guys kind of like encourage
women to like
marry when they're younger maybe not my
age but uh
as young as possible
um what about when guys get to
um
what about when we now grow up chica I'm
saying like what's stopping men from
sorry I was talking about from looking
at other women
I'll answer that one because I'm in a
long-term relationship and I love my
woman so I'm at an age where
this person understands me she's
agreeable she's submissive I'm not
controlling her I don't do control I
don't tell you what to do but we have an
understanding you know what I like you
know what I don't like I know you like
you know where am I going like because
there comes a time where it's you know
another woman I don't even want to be
crude it's just enough of a JJ with
another problem and issues that I'm not
prepared to deal with so I'm just doing
my thing I'm just making sure that I'm
into the mic sorry I'm just making sure
that I'm thriving I'm trying to be
successful for me and my family because
that's now my family and I'm responsible
for them all you know so that's that's
kind of
if you're giving your man what he needs
and his understanding I think
you know you you should be all right but
it depends on what level of man you're
looking for so if you're looking for
this Mr high value you know I've got
money I jump on Jets I got a business
call I'm going to be spending the night
in Toronto then you know what you're
gonna get well that's why some girls
like NBA wives
they know their men are cheating they
know he's got five Side sales and I
don't feel bad for any of them like that
girl that was dating Jason Derulo
and she wanted to come out and cry
because Jason Derulo cheated on her what
did you think you were gonna get you
dated Jason Derulo even even
ugly face Wayne Rooney
he was with the old woman prostitute
the old woman is Mrs still there he's
been found numerous times high value he
is he generates Millions even though
he's not even playing football anymore
she's not going nowhere wish again
she she knows what the deal is women
will stay over for legacy right they
understand right I'm creating Legacy see
my children them just being Rooney
yeah opens doors for them yeah and and
they're looking for that's what women
are looking for you're looking for the
price to breed your children to be
successful and be you know well that's
why the the you know being a single
mother is like a woman's mating strategy
because she gets the the jeans from the
first guy and then she gets the parental
investment from the second guy
there you go so it's like a mating
strategy
hmm
so what age
after all that so
the age to like stop dating
um
I'd say for men I do agree in terms of
that there's become a point where it's
like okay you may have like all the
money and all that kind of stuff but
it's kind of like
uh
um I'd say for men like
maybe like 45
I would date a 45 year old well
uh you're 21 right I probably wouldn't
about to yeah but it's kind of it's kind
of weird there's a weird thing that
happens at like 23 to like 26 where
you're like are dads hot like it's a
it's a really weird phase I promise you
it'll happen one day where because when
I was 21 when I heard a guy that was 30
I was like oh bro like I can't do 30.
and then now I'm like I could do 45 like
that's fine I don't know I don't maybe I
haven't reached that point yet but um
yeah I don't know I say for a man like
45 because personally I wouldn't date
someone that's 45 years old that's way
too old for me but
um women
when do you stop dating
um what would I say I'd say like we're
45 so what are women going
around I know
um I'd say oh
I'd say like
I say 40. 40 okay okay
I can't
play an age on it
okay 60.
too old to be there it's just like why
would you stop dating like if you
haven't found your personal world you
store but I'm saying for love like when
is love off the table
I don't know if I believe in love I
don't know if I believe in love I think
it's just a compromise
regardless of what age I think it's a
compromise
I don't know about love
what do you think
I was just that's so sad I believe in
love
um yeah I said what I thought about
primary school once you've got kids once
they got Prime once you've got kids at
primary school then once they've left
stop dating
because there's no point but if you're
single you've got no children
okay earlier yeah
for a man or you said no oh man they can
go on forever never never
um I think
men at the age of
I must say 60 for men I I give you 60.
yeah I'll give you 60. as long as you're
like
in shape you got your [ __ ] together yeah
like 60s a good time to
if you're not in a long-term
relationship
yeah but women and we're talking about
love we're not just talking about any
random thing we're talking about it's
not looking I'd say about like yeah this
is tough in it it is yeah like we're
talking about like this woman hasn't
been in a relationship so she hasn't got
like
yeah single single yeah widowed no no no
Widow oh no Widow okay then uh one of
the 50 of women that are single and
childless over 30. yeah maybe 40. yeah
maybe you'd say 40 for women I'm gonna
say 40.
maybe maybe that's what I would say
maybe 35 32 33. okay I'd give you I give
them like
no I reckon they can still have it at
33.
no
no
I am I'm literally like thinking of
examples yeah
that'd be tough yeah